let's get to John Burroughs how are you
John do you know the city a happy trade
deadline to you actually I've been
trying feverishly in the last couple
minutes just to get some sourcing and
some information on the a-rod cake yes I
will endeavor to get some responses from
Matt best version gets the firsthand
reporting on that but that was quite a
baseball event it was and the fact that
the cake got put on irrevocable waivers
is a shot on the baseball terminology
nobody touched it nobody touched it the
the cake refused the assignment to
Triple A clearly did look the plates are
on they've got a whole bunch of plates
and plastic cutlery I can't I don't
understand it alright John let's get to
the actual task at hand you know your
colleague from Yahoo Tim Brown says that
there is engagement between the Giants
and Astros on Madison Bumgarner what are
you hearing about him well I still think
rich that it's likely that Bumgarner
stays put in San Francisco I think that
far on xiety would not be doing his job
here in these final hours before the
deadline if he did not entertain the the
offers or the interest from a club like
Houston in in Bumgarner but candidly
rich there that the Giants are now above
500 they are still a good distance back
in the NL wild-card race but they're at
least part of it
and given the way they played there is a
I think a strong sentiment among their
fans which is important given how they
drawn the support they get there in San
Francisco that the way they played over
the last month the fact this is Bruce
Bochy last year all of the connections
that bum Connors got to the championship
clubs that here in San Francisco are all
pointing in the direction right now
Bumgarner staying but I do think it's
notable that there's at least some
conversation and I believe that the
Giants are overwhelmed by an offer from
the Astros which would likely include
Kyle Tucker of course a very highly
regarded the outfield prospect but
Houston has
that could potentially tip the scales
into the giant's favor of doing a deal
but I think short of that which I would
say that the chances of Bumgarner
staying in San Francisco are still right
now better than 5050 well what about the
chance of Bumgarner winding up in the
American League East Division John well
it's a great question and it's certainly
the the New York Yankees they've got a
little bit more to offer right now than
what the Astros do but again I think
that the tricky part rich here and we're
going to find out a lot about the
industry in the next 24 hours the the
relatively light return that the Blue
Jays got for Stroman on Sunday is
frustrating a lot of the activity right
now because the the teams that have
pitching to sell including insurance
with Bumgarner or the Diamondbacks with
Robby ray and Zack Greinke the Tigers
with Matthew Boy the Mets still with
Noah syndergaard and Zack wheeler the
the price for Stroman was low enough
that now the buyers for pitching are
saying wait a minute I'm not going to
give you a top 20 prospect Marcus
Stroman is under contract through next
year or at least under control through
salary arbitration and and he did not
even net back a top 100 prospect going
to Toronto in that trade so that I think
is depressing some of the the offers
right now rich which I think are really
it's all frustrating the process well
we're basically now 26 hours away to the
deadline and I am stunned at the lack of
action so far and that would even
include the fact that that Bumgarner is
someone who the Yankees certainly like
and the Yankees like Matthew Boyd they
like Mike miner they like Robbie rail
they like a lot of guys but I just think
the the price based on the way things
were set on Sunday with a sterling deal
has in many ways stymied a lot of the
the conversation I think it's pushed the
buyers and sellers further apart on what
the fair market price actually is all
right so let's take this one at a time
here the Mets what the hell are they
doing an excellent question my friend
and one that we are hearing a lot around
the industry this is confusing it has to
begin I think if we're going to talk
about the men
you got to begin by talking about how
grody bandwagon and got this job and
from talking to sources last winter time
Brody had told ownership there that that
he could take this job and that they
would not have to do a rebuild that was
what he said this this team can win now
with some modifications if you hire me I
will help you win in the next couple
years without having to do a rebuild and
that was the genesis of the Cano trade
and Diaz and of course that trade
immediately has not worked out for the
Mets to win that trade they would have
had to win a division or a playoff berth
basically this year next year and
they're already over one and unless they
really change things around for next
year it's not gonna have a next year
either and so they're I think they're
just trying to make it they move as they
can now to change the conversation and
change the roster and and getting
strolling I think they got them at a
fair price but to your point rich at to
what end where are you going with this
and if at the end of the day they're
able to trade winner for it to return in
syndergaard for a good return in the
next day then I think they can at least
say you know what we've got a
competitive Club we've got a player in
strohman from Long Island it comes back
home that's a good story and you can
sell to New York I get that but I unless
they're able to trade
syndergaard and wheeler for really good
returns that almost restock the system
of the guys that gave up to get Cano and
Diaz then it's just a merry-go-round and
and they're they're spinning in place
here and oh by the way the Braves are a
much better Club than them there's even
write out the Nationals are - and the
Phillies you probably would say are as
well so there they're stuck right now in
the middle rich and it's the in
isolation the Stroman deal was a fair
exchange for them but I'm just not sure
that the Mets really know where all this
is going based on what I'm seeing them
doing right now I mean to use the few
good men analogy John Merrow see of MLB
Network the fans are I guess syndergaard
is Santiago the fans have ordered him
not to be touched
then why are they ordering a Code Red on
syndergaard what
what what possible reason could they
have for taking a clear a list pitcher
who the fans love and gives the Mets
name recognition in a Yankee town with
all due respect why in the world is he
even being moved or considered to be
moved that and bringing in strowman for
what I mean I don't understand what
they're trying to achieve and how that
might affect the next 24 hours John what
do you want it's a very very fair point
Richard and I think the reason why you
would trade syndergaard now is that you
feel as though the Cano Diaz deal was a
mistake okay what do they want to admit
that or not this is this is them
throwing the car in reverse say wait a
minute dad that was not a good idea
get me something because what they've
done and this is where you really get in
trouble if you mistime your window if
you if you tell yourself or your owner
that you're ready to win and you're
actually not and you make moves in that
direction then you're in trouble because
you've been given up your better
prospects which the Mets did in that
trade and now all of a sudden you look
wait a minute
we're not as good in the present as we
thought we were going to be and now we
have sent ourselves back for the future
so that's a really bad place to be in
New York or anywhere in the United
States look at the play baseball they're
in a bad spot and so the the reason
Trade Center guard is that you feel as
though you could at least get back some
of the value that you lost in a trade
that's clearly not working out so at
least I would give them credit for the
old adage of when you're when you're
digging a hole stop digging and then try
to thread it let's reassess things
that's kind of what they're doing now
except rich the problem here is they've
got a picture in cinder guard who do
your point is popular in New York and is
not necessarily having his best season
in fact he's having a sports so how much
of a fix is it to really trade someone
who have had great value at a time when
his value is down now he's the last you
guys have been better and he's been
scouted and teams know what he's got but
I am
very skeptical they'll be able to get
fair value at least what they think his
value is based on what he's done in the
past based on the fact that he's having
a little bit of a down year by his own
standards and by the way which I would
say this and you certainly know this
from your connections to New York I
would just say the chances of him of
syndergaard being traded to the Yankees
are effectively zero I just do not see
any any plausible way they deal in in
the city and and trade away one of the
more recognizable players to their
archrival at least in terms of winning
the back page headline well if the
Astros go ahead and get Bumgarner it
doesn't matter how much the Yankees been
raking and how well they've performed
through the first two-thirds of the
season and and how they've been overcome
injuries I mean that's a wrap I mean and
then the same thing with the twins and
the Indians and the Red Sox I mean that
would be I mean how do you go in October
and it's Bumgarner Cole Verlander that
lineup that manager that building that
spot I mean I don't even know how that
would be I mean the Dodgers the Dodgers
they're not gonna get Bumgarner clearly
but I mean the Dodgers would have to be
concerned about that if the Astros get
Bumgarner no question and and the
interesting thing here rich is a couple
things on that topic number one the
Astros they are so leveraged right now
for this year they've got Miley who's
been a consistent order for them this
year he's a free agent after the season
as his Gerrit Cole and as would be
Bumgarner if they got him so this is I'm
not saying it's at the end of their
window because they've got a really
great lineup he's good for a while but
they're gonna have to totally remake
their pitching this winter if they want
to be competitive next year because it's
basically they've got Verlander and very
little else in the rotation for sure for
next year as it stands right now that's
why I think they actually while they're
talking about Bumgarner they may
actually prefer someone like in math you
boys because they got more years of
control on a boy but the Dodger point
that you mentioned which I think it's
fascinating this to me is the defining
question of this trade deadline how
desperate are the Dodgers to win the
World Series because you've gotten to
the World Series in back-to-back years
you built a very sustainable great farm
system at least a very good one and and
you've got a closer right
now who is wobbly Kelly Johnson has
looked vole nerville at different times
of season I believe and I realized you
know that the pressure is unique in each
market but Dodger fans cannot stand I
believe for this team to get to the
World Series again and have the bullpen
let them down again that's that's
unacceptable I I would feel that way if
I were a pyro Dodger fan and that's why
I think Felipe Vasquez in Pittsburgh is
the guy now there was a report from
Buster Olney that insisting on Gavin
walks through the Dodge vest minor
league hitter he is phenomenal and I
think if that's the price I think the
Dodgers could safely say no and I would
say that's probably the right is it
could be that good but anybody else in
that system they've got a number of
names dustin may is a name Kiba ruiz of
the name if i'm the dodgers I give up
both of those players to get baskets
because he's under control for multiple
years and rich I just I think for a team
it's come so close and you know that
Janssen is vulnerable you can't go into
the World Series again and lose it
because of that reason when your team is
that good and it's almost almost
flawless almost but the lack of one
major late inning lefty is a pretty
noticeable weakness for them and they've
got to address it today or tomorrow all
right bye it's 4:00 Eastern tomorrow is
that when the deadline is okay and now
you're part of MLB network's 13 hours of
trade deadline coverage tomorrow
beginning at 10:00 a.m. Eastern Time I
will be keeping a close eye John on your
on your Eagle Scout reporting of the
a-rod birthday cake that was somehow
delivered by Jennifer Lopez during
Sunday Night Baseball and then uneaten
untouched John there's something I
thought you got to give it a get to the
bottom of it
okay you're a certain Ann Arbor
sometimes it's the ball to watch the
favorite victim champ that we think
Michigan take care of John you got it
we'll chat soon but that's John Merrow
see I'm hoping Network Cubs Cardinals
tonight and they'll be Network at 8:00
Eastern Time for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app